allora ragazzi sono circa due settimane
che non registro qualcosa perché fa un
naso tappa tissimo non so se si sente
nel video in caso perdonate andato a
trovare i miei genitori per natale e
sono rimasto fuori fino ad oggi mi sono
preso questa pausa perché per fare lo
speciale di 5 milioni ci abbiamo
veramente impiegato un mese un mese dove
quando stiamo per arrivare ai 5 milioni
e web stralciando e ci siamo seduti
abbiamo detto ok cosa possiamo fare però
605 milioni non può essere uno speciale
normale dove in genere faccio vedere i
momenti epici che è sempre un bel modo
di festeggiare
siccome è speciale come traguardo
rispetto agli altri abbiamo deciso di
fare qualcosa di completamente diverso
spero non sia valsa la pena ma a quanto
pare che si è visto che video ha fatto
due milioni di dischi e tantissimo in
realtà che altro stata una soddisfazione
perché come dicevo prima noi ci siamo
seduti come sociale abbiamo detto che
vogliamo fare qualcosa di diverso che
avendo però abbiamo cercato di tirare su
questo video io all'inizio dicevo perché
l'ora mi han dato l'idea ma invitiamo
tutti sti vip e ha detto ma se sicuri
che riusciamo organizzare tutta questa
cosa nell'arco di tre settimane in
realtà non era neanche un mese un po
meno ci siamo riusciti a una festa di
chi è stato meno grazie anche al mio
team che sono riusciti a fare questa
cosa grazie a lorenzo grazie a tutti
quanti si sono sbattuti dal primo
all'ultimo bello stressante perché
comunque come vedete dalle riprese
eravamo in continuo movimento cioè noi
andavamo da un vip
poi facciamo la scena poi gliela
dovevamo spiegare poi non tutti si
prestano a fare bene che ti può recitare
con favino favino le fa le cose favino è
un attore figure non riesce però tipo
che ne so j ax jovanotti insomma sono
cantanti quindi è difficile fargli fare
determinate cose invece se la sono
cavata tutti egregiamente è stato
veramente figo super soddisfatto
io avevo un'aspettativa prima che
uscisse questo video pensavo riuscisse
in un certo modo è uscito molto meglio
cioè uscito veramente meglio di quanto
pensassi e quindi sbattersi da una parte
all'altra col van
la troupe cederà è veramente ne è valsa
n'è valsa la pena è stato un video
divertentissimo da registrare che mi ha
fatto conoscere un sacco di persone e io
sono veramente convinto del fatto che
prima o poi riusciremo a fare un'altra
cosa del genere non presto però perché
mi sono ora ci siamo anzi ammazzati però
prima o poi di fare un altro insomma del
genere e proprio divertente veramente
divertente la cosa che ho capito che fa
la differenza quando fai un lavoro rehn
strutturato tipo questo è che la
differenza la fa quando la troupe oltre
che te la troupe ma dal dal primo
all'ultimo prodotta da chi trucca non sa
che centro catanese è un esempio questo
è un esempio a chi riprende quando ogni
singola persona che compone il team ci
crede cioè non lo fa solo per lavoro lo
fa per lavoro si perché sono tutti
pagati insomma per fare queste cose ma
il moltiplicatore mettiamola così di
qualità del contenuto che state vedendo
è dovuto al fatto che le persone che lo
stanno facendo ci stanno veramente
credendo perché se una persona non ci
crede lo fa solo per finire il compitino
quindi solo per lavoro il video esce non
è venuto nessuno la festa però ragazzi
che posso dirvi io qua c'è ancora la
villa di george ancora il biglietto
quindi ci proviamo quando arrivava 10
milioni cipro
[Musica]
ai 5 milioni e 5 mila nella finestra del
giorno io la sposti in quel giorno
quand'è che poi nel corto ecco male ma è
rimasto male si sia sincero troppo
lavoro
questo prologo mia figlia natale e poi
mai non puoi fare il taglio vivo questa
è una casa di tutti al quadro poi quando
poi ti fa quando poi insieme alla troupe
c'era anche questo questo ragazzo che
faceva il backstage e quindi le scene
che state vedendo la ripresa lui di
ragazzi invece che vedete costantemente
inquadrato quello con la barbetta il
nick bello delle iene che ha avuto
insomma la costanza di seguimi in ogni
scena ringrazio anche nick ma ringrazio
tutta la troupe che si è sbattuta dal
primo all'ultimo anche dal ragazzo del
backstage che senza di lui non avrete
derby senza di lui non avreste questo
video resta adesso che ripartiamo spero
che i contenuti vi piacciono perché
adesso inizierò a lavorare sui nuovi sui
nomi formata anche tra parentesi
ho constatato che su youtube c'è stato
un cambiamento a livello di gusti
insomma una volta andavano tanto le
serie ho notato invece adesso
nell'ultimo periodo che le serie non si
reca capi nessuno sceglie le serie
horror almeno quelle rpg anche ho sempre
fatto non se li caga proprio più nessuno
mi sa che interromperò questa cosa qua
perché comunque io faccio questo sia
perché il mio hobby ma anche perché il
mio lavoro e quindi devo anche pensare a
cosa piace al pubblico oltre che cosa
piace a me piacevano sempre le solite
del pg non mi vedo così costretto a
trovare altro perché vedo che ad esempio
unboxing fa vigilia un miliardo di views
mentre il giorno prima la serie ne ha
molte ma proprio un infinità meno tipo
quando ciccio game erano portafortuna
non è un dissing tranquillo tranquilli
quindi spero che i video vi sia piaciuto
adesso inizieranno nove nuovi progetti
nuove robe semi bassa raffreddore magari
inizia a parlare normalmente come al
solito ragazzi se il video è piaciuto
lascia documento è un mi piace se non
l'avete visto lo speciale ma dubito
perché sono che incassata guardato video
se non si sa da quale si chiede e noi ci
chiediamo come sempre prossimo
[Musica]